we were talking about flying and like
one of my friends sent the picture of
like that proposed you like cabin new
cabin or whatever on
like seats yes stack person fting
imagine ripping a fart yeah sometimes
they like we all do it at least me like
I rip ass on farts on farts I rip farts
on ass farts on ass fart I ass on farts
all the time dude no but I fart on
planes all the time yeah why are I'm
Shameless about it now cuz I'm like no
one knows it's me what is this youever
know what is this lie they're telling
with that uh seat back positioning no
shot they would give anyone that amount
of comfort on that seat this is so funny
that girl yeah that girl's eating a fart
right there yeah in that picture she's
eating a fart he just farted in my mouth
and I liked
it I love yum I don't even need pretzels
I love when Comfort plus I love when
Comfort plus farts in my mouth then I
know exactly what that Comfort plus
dinner meal tastes like yeah if you were
sitting on the top row yeah would you
fart ye bro yes but like would you fart
more often or less often oh no yeah
they'd be like what would you like to
drink sir um could I get two glasses of
milk a d of coke a coffee what's the
spiciest thing you have on the
plane holy
hell it's these damn lro man you two of
them both both opened cuz I'm on the
second
one it's been 30 minutes no dude he had
his upper decker Comfort plus meal oh
that's even better when you're farting
in their mouth and you're sitting in the
upper deck seat upper decker yeah yeah
giving them literally an upper decker
yeah oh that's true yeah yeah if your
upper deck behind the head of the lower
deck oh yeah true yeah you could like
just you could just like grip the
[__] thing burp into their you know I
thinking worse like they're
sleeping
[Laughter]
dude
fing Oh I thought I had a fart damn it
would have been so great be so great if
you [__] yourself so good if you [__]
yourself
man take that
yeah take that loser take that loser
[__] my pants take that loser enjoy that
a
now now I got a butt
Taco N I got butt
beef oh man somebody just [__] on my
pants and it was me farting in your hand
just cupping on their nose how does that
smell good
[Laughter]
morning yo dude your meal
arrived smacking it in their mouth
yo dude breakfast is
here tast
it they fall asleep with their mouth
[Laughter]
open imagine being a lower deck having
to go ass to piss yeah walking over
people hi do you sorry
[Laughter]
yeah how would you get up and get out
it's so
true just
[__] sorry sorry I really have to
[__]
sorry [__] this
way sorry
[Laughter]
I was [__] laughing so hard on my
flight back from uh
Nashville uh it was an older plane and I
was just laughing at the angle that you
have to try to sleep on just an older
smaller plane I'm like leaning with my
head you know just I I was sleeping on
my forehead and I was my body position
was
this yeah
yeah I love trying to sleep on this yeah
no shot just never worked ever but it
feels like it's like so close to being
comfortable yeah you know and then
you're like these why don't they have a
head
strap that would be just awesome just
[__] oh yeah why don't they why can't
they Saran wrap me and put me in the
cargo yeah
seriously why can't they put me in a
suitcase why can't I get naked why put
like why can't they just let me wear
come on
man you're trying to fire up the viewers
with this one yeah see I would
probably what guy like me guy like me
like me I it'd be me in that stir up
yeah
seriously be me putting my [__] balls
out there you know what I'm saying no
they could actually stack people like
this pretty effectively they could what
the [__] like convention is
this what like what airplane interior
conference no this is like the yeah an
aviation conference just for the CEOs
yeah and they're just laughing at this
[__] oh my God imagine having to oh oh
my God this is [__]
horrible look at this I love it I love
it oh my God look at this [__] my knees
Bob check it out check it out I'm a
regular
person hey hey a one economy ticket
please oh I'm so comfy
hey who Am I who am I ow my knees
yeah yeah dude oh this is sick this is a
trick they're making this look
comfortable this is a trick no this does
look comfortable but it would never be
like this is this a train
though that looks awesome there's no way
they'd ever do this it's way too nice
all right let's move on from air travel
we've been doing this for 47 minutes I
mean it is objectively hilarious to look
at a seat that should we hit airplane
food anything there not not really not
really I was just going to say that
chair looks like a diaper changing
station wait which one go back this one
yeah yeah oh that that this would suck
be so
bad you're listening on audio I don't
really know why though it's not really
any different from no dude that'd be
terrible yeah so if you're on audio what
this is It's a typical air airplane like
three seat row but the middle chair is
flipped around that's so awkward man
you're just
like bro you just watching porn in front
of two people yeah no but they couldn't
see oh yes like no they couldn't no but
that's cuz your screen would be fac I
know it be funny if it's just like you
had it loud enough in your headphones
and you're just smiling at
them yeah that would be weird like being
fa to face with someone
[Laughter]
yeah where are you headed
I'm just watching a movie
yeah where are you guys headed in the
yeah airpod
is why you going to Cleveland business
or
pleasure I got a bit of a layover so uh
I got time to kill if you know what I
mean good talking to
[Music]
you
damn